tomorrow marks june 1st and the
beginning of pride month our pride
celebrations will run all month long on
et canada and you can check out even
more content anytime at etcanada.com
pride yes and we are starting the
celebrations early with jessie j who
stopped her recent concert to share a
touching message to heart stopper star
joe olaki i don't know if it's locker or
lockheed so i will say both don't want
to disrespect the netflix coming of age
star in the lgbtq plus love story based
on the popular graphic novel people love
this show it hurt 100 rating on rotten
tomatoes and has been renewed forget
this a second and third season already
well done and if you're a heart stopper
fan this will make your day even more as
jessie j took the time to thank joe for
helping someone close to her take a look
and we will see you next time
it just gets really up tempo and intense
i just have to say thank you you won't
understand why
but you are a wonderful person and
you're helping someone really close to
me gets for a really tough time so thank
you
i appreciate you